On cold, dark winter nights, you might catch
a glimpse of a horned figure stalking through
the streets.
With a basket strapped to its back and a switch
in hand, the demonic Krampus isn’t interested
in giving gifts but doling out brutal punishments.
Krampus is the dark foil to St. Nicholas,
the miraculous Catholic bishop credited with
bringing small gifts of sweets, nuts, and
fruit to good little boys and girls in early
December (and yes, one of the inspirations
behind jolly old you-know-who).
But what are the origins of the demonic horned
creature?
You might be surprised to learn this winter
monster isn’t as old as you might have been
led to believe.
And even more importantly—why invent a Yuletide
character that literally beats children into
submission?
[Monstrum Intro.]
The Krampus’s historical origins are generally
believed to have emerged onto the Yuletide
scene in Slavic and Austrian celebrations.
Winter festivals in the Alpine regions of
Austria, Hungary, Slovenia, Croatia, Germany,
and Italy all feature versions of this monstrous
anti-Santa, though originally “Krampus”
was really more of a category of monster rather
than the name of an individual creature.
The word itself comes either from the Middle
German for ‘claw’ (Kralle) or the Bavarian
word for something lifeless and dried out
(Krampn), with plenty of regional variations
[Kramperl, Klaubauf, Tuifl].
Half-goat, half-demon, Krampus are fanged,
with cloven feet and often long, pointed tongues.
The oldest and most traditional versions have
multiple sets of horns.
They may carry a pitchfork and a basket to
collect children in.
And they always have that switch in their
hand—most often one made of birch branches.
The better to beat you with, my dear.
Yep, that’s what this charming monster does—doles
out corporal punishment to children who misbehave.
Krampus emerged in Alpine folklore alongside
celebrations of St. Nicholas.
At first it was more of an idea—an amorphous,
threatening boogeyman parents evoked to keep
kids in line when food was scarce and attention
wavered during the long dark nights of winter
in the mountains.
Nice children received presents from St. Nick,
naughty children received a birch branch spanking
from Krampus, or worse.
The most wickedly behaved were shackled and
tossed into the monster’s wooden basket
to be carried away to the fires of Hell.
Or, y’know, eaten by the Krampus.
The traditions connecting Krampus and St.
Nicholas seem interwoven through time, despite
some conflicting versions of how they came
to be associated.
There is evidence of performances that link
the Krampus to Satan in Jesuit theatre and
the monster frequently appears in St. Nicholas
plays, so it is possible that the beast was
constructed to represent the opposite of divinity.
Detailed descriptions of Krampus only emerge
in the 19th century when folklorists began
recording the costumes worn during Krampuslauf
[Krampus-laouf], or “Krampus run.”
In the Alpine region, December 5 marks a celebratory—and
usually drunken—parade in which people dressed
as Krampus walk through the streets, scaring
bystanders, and chasing down the really unlucky
ones.
Even if people dressed as Krampus don’t
actually injure people they are a symbolic
threat of violence and rebellion against decorum.
In some regions, Krampus troops stalk the
streets from November to Christmas.
These troops consist of multiple revelers,
and it's considered an honor, and often a
rite of passage to don the horns.
In the oldest traditions of the Alpine region,
Krampus revelers would either blacken their
faces, don a dark false beard, and dress in
dark clothing, or they wore wooden masks and
long fur coats, sporting belts with large
bells, and that switch in their hand, of course.
In Catholic areas, where fear of the devil
was stronger, the costume included horns to
highlight their evil nature.
​​Krampus masks are often called “Larven”
from the Latin word larva that means both
mask and ghost.
Traditional masks are grotesque; with exaggerated
features and gaping mouths, accented by massive
animal horns—usually multiple pairs from
different animals.
The woodcarvers who craft these masks are
considered well-respected masters.
Also in the mid-19th century, the monster
became associated with Santa Claus, the more
secular version of St. Nicholas.
Around this time is also where we see the
moniker ‘Krampus’ emerge.
In 1862, a newspaper in Budapest was published
under Krampus’s name [Krampuszok ], and
in 1865 it published an image of Santa Claus
with Krampus lurking behind him, solidifying
the creature’s appearance and transferring
the connection to the Christian holiday of
Christmas rather than the holy saint’s feast
day.
Claims that Krampus is derived from pagan
traditions intending to drive away winter
and evil spirits in an ancient fertility rite
are unfounded— in reality, there is no evidence
for this.
Scholars found that the false pagan origin
story of Krampus was invented in the early
20th century by socialist folklorists attempting
to cast Christianity as a practice that sullied
ancient Nordic customs.
The Nazi Party reinforced this false claim,
publishing a photo essay portraying the Krampus
as an “ancient custom” “banned for its
pagan roots.”
In reality, Krampus nights weren’t recorded
until 1582 in the Bavarian town of Diessen
in passing reference under the name Percht.
The Perchten are mischievous Alpine spirits
and the likely folkloric precursors to the
Krampus.
Documents from the 17th and 18th centuries
show Salzburg archbishops trying to ban the
Krampus tradition—with little success.
Interestingly, these bans were not about the
monster itself but were aimed at curbing the
raucous celebrations that accompanied them.
In the 19th century, the Krampuslauf tradition
dwindled, preserved only in a small number
of Austrian and German towns until the 1870s
as consumerism boomed.
More specifically, red postcards with illustrations
of the monster appeared in Austria-Hungary
in the later-half of the century.
Austria’s postal system became the first
to deliver postcards in 1867—making the
sending of Krampus cards in the late 1880s
possible, and financially viable.
The cards became incredibly popular, a nostalgic
reminder for Austrians and Germans who moved
from rural areas where Krampus runs were popular,
to industrialized cities.
Unsurprisingly, these postcards often show
the horned monster punishing children.
Or, in a seemingly bizarre twist, accompanied
by semi-naked women.
Perhaps because of these associations with
both youth and sexuality, in some parts of
Austria, children are told that being hit
with Krampus’s switch brings fertility.
While globally Krampus’ popularity suffered
from the early-20th century associations with
Socialism and the Nazi Party, in the later
part of the century the demonic figure has
made a comeback.
Since the turn of the 21st century, Krampus
events have become larger and more numerous
across the globe.
Whether this is due to a renewed interest
in preserving traditional regional customs
as globalization emerges, or a rebellious
response to the over commodification and commercialization
of Christmas—the death metal version of
Santa is making a play to take back the winter
holidays.
The Internet’s discovery of the 19th century
Krampus cards brought renewed interest to
the monster.
In 2012 an episode of the Scooby-Doo!
Mystery Incorporated cartoon focused on the
Krampus.
And that same year, Gerald Brom’s book Krampus:
the Yule Lord, further increased the popularity
of the monster—and connected him to a false
backstory in Nordic mythology and made him
an enemy of Santa Claus.
Movies, books, and other popular culture texts
in America have perpetuated the connection
between Santa and Krampus.
Horror films featuring the Krampus emerged
around 2010, and the monster has been a staple
ever since.
The 2015 film Krampus plays on the Santa Claus/Krampus
connection explicitly—with Krampus coming
down chimneys, wearing a red fur-trimmed coat—and
slaughtering people.
Commercialism, morbid fascination, reclamation—whatever
draws people to Krampus allows tradition to
be shared and preserved.
In 2014, UNESCO even declared the Krampus-play
of the town of Oblarn in Styria as vital to
the cultural heritage of humanity.
Which proves to me that it’s not only the
good guys that get immortalized—the monsters
get their place in history too.
So this winter holiday season don’t forget
to play nice boys and girls—or you might
get a visit from this Yuletide monster.